all this week on 8 news now we will be
remembering victims honoring survivors
and paying tribute to the First
Responders of one October 58 people died
that night in a mass shooting at the
Route 91 Harvest Festival in front of
Mandalay Bay the death toll would
eventually rise to 60. so this year
marks five years since that tragedy and
tonight anchor Heather Mills introduces
us to a woman who found her path to
Healing by leaving Las Vegas
she wasn't running away rather she was
moving toward a Stillness that she
wasn't able to find with this site
nearby I remember saying like all I want
is peace in the Years following the
Route 91 tragedy Anna Hendrick says she
did everything she could to regain a
sense of normalcy she went to therapy
she went to concerts she helped honor
the lives lost but Las Vegas which was
home just didn't feel the same I think
there's an underlying feeling that's
always there in the city and for her and
her three boys that meant it was time to
move on even to this day I love Vegas
but
um Tennessee's healthy for us Tennessee
is a place that I have been able to heal
it gets healthy for them to see me
healing when it comes to dealing with
trauma there really is no right or wrong
it's what works for you Jackie Harris is
a behavioral health consultant for the
Vegas strong resiliency Center she's
been counseling survivors since that
tragic night on October 1st with trauma
it's not something we quote get over you
learn to live a full and healthy and
happy life Joanna says that life for her
family is in Tennessee it's different
out here it's very different it's
healthier my oldest said I would never
leave here because it's safe his
birthday actually falls on October 1st
and Joanna says this year they can
finally celebrate without the tragedy
casting a shadow this is the first year
in five years that it kind of just gets
to be all about him she says they'll
continue their 58 random acts of
kindness to honor the lives lost but
this year offers A New Beginning Harris
says Milestone years can evoke very
strong emotions so she reminds all of us
everyone heals at their own pace and in
their own time Heather Mills eight news
now